this is captain Kimberly our medical
officer and these are some of our men
eating their evening meal as usual at
the end of another routine day yes
everything seems to be going well
just another day but believe me what
followed turned out to be anything but
routine this meal is the beginning of
our story a story that developed during
the night and continued for several days
during the early part of the night we
all went about our duties as usual
everything was nice and smooth and quiet
the way we like to see things wrong
at midnight about 40 of us in the duty
section got a light meal it was just
about this time that things were
beginning to happen it began like this
at first a few of the men who weren't in
the duty section got sick more followed
suit and just before dawn
most of the men who had the midnight
meal join their ranks you never saw such
a sick bunch of men in your life and it
got steadily worse vomiting abdominal
pains and diarrhea it was hard to tell
which caused the most trouble
one thing is sure the boys were well
taken care of some of them at the base
infirmary and others at a private
hospital in town
for a while all we had time to do was
bring in the sick and some of them were
plenty sick get them in bed and leave
them to captain Kimberly and his
assistants
it was pretty rough going for a while
vomiting diarrhea cramps headache
sweating prostration fever and
dehydration yes Salmonella can make you
plenty sick just as soon as we got the
chance to let up and breathe a little we
got down to the business of finding the
cause of all the trouble naturally we
had suspected some kind of food
poisoning and so it was look here this
is what we found these are Salmonella
organisms of the species typhimurium
which were isolated from a patient stool
specimen from the lapse of time between
our patients last meal and the outbreak
of illness it was pretty evident that
the evening meals were responsible for
the presence of the Salmonella organisms
in the stool specimen in the meantime
our laboratory was working on samples of
food eaten that night
sampling incubating plating transfer and
then more incubating laboratory
examinations require time and it may
take several days to identify the
organisms our results show that the
other foods were okay but the samples of
leftover chicken and the gravy reveal
the same bacteria as the stool specimens
of the patients for these two were
thoroughly contaminated with Salmonella
typhimurium how and when did the chicken
and the gravy become contaminated with
the organisms well here's one thing
we'll have to assume but it's a pretty
safe assumption one or more of these
chickens were contaminated by the
Salmonella organisms on the outside and
very likely inside and of course the
liver and gizzard are prime suspects
during the cleaning operation this
cutting board was undoubtedly
contaminated
after the chickens were put in the oven
the giblets were cooked separately on
top of the stove
and the cutting board was clean but what
a cleaning it got maybe we should just
say that the Salmonella organisms were
more completely distributed over its
surface and embedded in the cracks
while the giblets were cooking a white
gravy was prepared
and then the giblets were taken from the
stove
Thoreau cooking had killed the
Salmonella organisms but this good clean
food was recontaminate Adan the cutting
board as it was chopped
then these recontaminate adju blitz were
put into the gravy
this contaminated gravy was not reheated
it was prepared for serving and on the
steam table there wasn't enough heat to
kill the organisms in fact there is a
good chance they began to grow
the story was much the same with the
chicken heat kill the Salmonella
organisms in the oven but again the
unclean cutting board contaminated the
safe chicken meat as it was carved or
serving
there wasn't much delay in getting the
chicken served
and between the gravy and the chicken we
can account for the men who were sick
around midnight or soon after those
acute cases that occurred later form
another chapter in our story here's how
the next chapter goes food left over
from the evening meal was saved for the
midnight meal and here in this lukewarm
steam table the Salmonella organisms
continued to grow
and to make matters worse the cutting
board contributed a new bunch of
organisms as the leftover chicken was
prepared for serving
so that by the time the midnight meal
was served the chicken a la king was
supporting large numbers of Salmonella
organisms enough to make the men on the
Night Watch so violently ill what could
have prevented this sickness and
suffering we couldn't know that the
chickens were infected look here this is
a detergent this is hot water this is a
brush these are hands put them together
use them and get a clean cutting board
with all the troublemakers washed off a
good scrubbing immediately after the raw
chicken was prepared would have gotten
rid of the Salmonella organisms of
course this applies to our hands and
anything else that might be contaminated
by contact with the fowl we made some
other mistakes too the leftover chicken
should have been put into the
refrigerator as soon as possible and the
gravy it was cooked before the
contaminated giblets were added donal
cooking after they were added would have
killed the Salmonella organisms the air
base mess-hall accommodated the men in
three shifts of approximately 150 at a
time out of some 450 regular personnel
173 became infected with salmonella --ss
of which 84 were seriously ill enough to
be hospitalized
all effected complete recovery and we're
back on duty within several days - about
two weeks